pues primero esta mañana empezó con la
visita al centro de acogida de afectados
por la erupción son más o menos 5000
personas vecinos de esta erupción que ha
tenido que ser evacuadas en total en las
próximas horas hasta 10.000 ciudadanos
podrían tener que abandonar sus casas
pedro sánchez se ha comprometido a
reparar todos los daños de estos vecinos
damnificados después asistió al comité
director de protección civil ahí se
mencionó del hecho que hay 180 militares
del efectivos de la unidad militar de
emergencia que tendrán que desplegarse
este lunes en la isla y 55 vehículos
también se activarán tres hidroaviones
dentro de una hora pedro sánchez tiene
otra visita irá a ver las zonas más
afectadas por la erupción el gobierno
español dice que está movilizado la
ministra de turismo ha querido enviar un
mensaje de tranquilidad a todos los
turistas que están en la isla y que van
a venir en los próximos días explicó que
de momento no hay ninguna restricción
para llegar a la isla en avión